Now on problem number 15.
When it is noon Eastern Standard
Time in New York
City, it is 9 am Pacific
Standard Time in San Francisco.
Well we know that.
There's a three hour difference
between New York
and San Francisco.
A plane took off from New
York City at noon
Eastern Standard Time.
So it takes off from New York
City at 12 noon Eastern
Standard Time.
What time is that in Pacific
Standard Time?
Well they're three hours back,
so that's also 9 Pacific
Standard Time.
A plane took off in New York
City at 12 noon Eastern
Standard Time and arrived at San
Francisco at 4 pm Pacific
Standard Time.
So this is am.
And so it goes to SFO, it goes
to San Francisco where I live.
I live a little south
of San Francisco.
But anyway, so it goes to San
Francisco and what time does
it get there?
It says 4 pm Pacific
Standard Time.
And we know that New York is
three hours ahead, so that's
Eastern Standard Time there,
so that's also 7 pm Eastern
Standard Time.
I'm an expert at this because I
work for a hedge fund where
all we do is schedule a lot
of calls with the company
management.
And they happen to, normally,
not be in the same time zone
as we are, so we're
pros at scheduling
calls across time zones.
So this is like second nature.
I'm enjoying this problem
more than most people.
Back to the problem.
If a second plane left San
Francisco at noon Pacific
Standard Time-- so at 12 pm
Pacific Standard Time, and
what is that?
That's also 3 pm Eastern
Standard Time-- and took the
exact, same amount of time for
the trip, what was the arrival
time Eastern Standard Time
in New York City?
So what time is it in Eastern
Standard Time?
So the first thing we just have
to figure out is how long
does the trip take, and then
do the second part.
So how long did this
trip take?
This plane left at 12 Eastern
and arrived at 7 pm Eastern,
so it took 7 hours.
And that was easy, because
we started from 12 and
we went to 7, right?
Similarly, if we're going to
leave at 3 pm Eastern Time--
because we want to stay in
Eastern Time, because our
final answer has to be Eastern
Time-- if we leave at 3 pm
Eastern Time and take 7 hours,
we're going to get there at 10
pm Eastern Standard Time,
which is choice A.
The trick of this problem is
really just staying in one,
consistent time zone
the whole time.
You could stay in, maybe, the
Eastern Standard Time the
whole time.
Next problem.
It looks like I'll have
to draw something.
I'll draw this rectangle.
I'll draw it in yellow.
So let's say this
is a rectangle.
And then I'll try my best to
draw some of these circles.
So we'll just look at the part
that's inside of the
rectangle, because I don't feel
like erasing all that
other stuff.
Well this is not perfect.
These points touch, right?
Actually, let me erase all that
other stuff, because it's
distracting.
So I'll erase this.
I'm trying my best
to draw neat.
Let me erase all of the rest
of the circle just so it
doesn't distract you from what's
already drawn there.
Almost done.
Sometimes I feel like that guy
who paints pictures on PBS,
because I spend so much time
drawing these diagrams. What's
his name, Bob?
OK.
So let's see, I was
using yellow.
Let me fill that in
a little bit.
OK.
What are the points
that they draw?
They say that that's point
Q, point P, point T,
point R, point S.
In rectangle P, Q, R, S above,
arcs Q, T and R, T are quarter
circles with centers
at P and S.
OK.
So these are quarter circles
with centers at P and S.
If the radius of each circle is
1-- so the radius is 1, so
this is 1, right?
Because this is a radius.
This is the radius of
the circle-- this
distance is also 1.
What is the area of
the shaded region?
So they drew the shaded
region as this.
That's the shaded
region they did.
So to figure that out we just
have to figure out the area of
the larger rectangle, and then
subtract out the areas of
these quarter circles.
So what's the area of this
larger rectangle?
Well we know its base because
this distance is 1, this
distance is 1.
And we know, in general,
that this radius is 1.
This distance is 1, and also
this distance is 1.
So the entire rectangle
is 2 by 1, right?
This is 1.
1 plus 1 is 2, 2 by 1.
So the area of the rectangle--
I'll call that area sub r-- is
equal to 2 times 1, which
is equal to 2.
Now we just have to figure
out the area of
these quarter circles.
So if I had a whole circle
with radius 1, what
would its area be?
So it would be area
is pi r squared.
And if the radius is 1, the area
would is equal to-- well
pi times 1 squared is
just pi, pi times 1.
So the area would be pi for
a full circle, right?
So the area for a quarter
circle-- I could do it in this
color-- the area of that
blue right there, would
be pi over 4, right?
Because it's a quarter
circle, this is pi/4.
And similarly, that one would
also be another pi over 4.
So the area of the shaded area
would be the area of the
rectangle, which is 2.
You probably can't even
see that blue.
The area of the rectangle is
2 minus the area of each of
these quarter circles,
minus pi over 4.
And so this would be 2 minus pi
over 2, which is choice B.
Next problem.
Looks like more drawing
for me.
OK.
So they drew this graph, and
I guess I will draw it too,
because the whole point of what
I'm doing is trying to
explain to you how to do these
problems. Let's see, so draw
my axes x and y.
And then the graph comes
in like this.
Then it dips down like this.
And then it goes up like this.
And they give us a couple
of points on the graph.
They say that this point
here is, 0, 1.
And they say that this point,
right there, is 1, 0.
And they say the graph of y
equals f of x is shown above.
So this is y is equal
to f of x.
Which of the following could be
the graph of y is equal to
f of x plus 2?
So if you've done this in
class, this is kind of a
traditional shifting problem.
So what you have to realize is,
when you take x plus 2--
before when you had,
let's say, when x--
let's put it this way.
Before when x and
f of-- and y.
Let's do x and y.
When x was equal to 0, y
was equal to 1, right?
And when x is equal 1,
y is equal to 0.
Now what happens
when x and y--
I still want to input 0
into f of x, right?
I still want to input 0 into f
of x, because f of 0 is going
to be the same thing.
But if I want to put 0 into f of
x, I have to put a negative
2 in here, right?
Now when x is equal to
negative 2, then this
expression here becomes 0,
right? f of negative 2 plus 2
is equal to 0, so that's equal
to the old f of 0.
So then that equals 1.
And if I wanted a 1 here, I
would have to put a minus 1 in
for x, right?
Think about it.
If I take a minus 1, and I input
it into this expression,
then I get f of 1, right?
If I put minus 1-- my phone
is ringing, it's slightly
distracting.
But anyway, focus.
I only have 30 seconds left.
But f of minus 1-- Actually, let
me continue this into the
next thing, and let me
answer my phone.